what does the computers have to do
they have videos of me doing this
he's just a wayward child guys he's just
a small child who's 51 years old
ah
well
at least he's not the president's son
hunter biden is apparently the smartest
person that joe biden knows
which is incredible because what this
means is that joe biden just spends his
days hanging around five-year-olds that
is the only plausible explanation for
how hunter biden is the smartest person
that he knows because kids are
unintelligent and hunter biden is really
unintelligent and so i have picked the
age of five because if you go to the age
of six hunter biden still would not be
the smartest person that joe biden knows
so now we have the story about hunter
biden
in which he violates all the rules of
prostitution
according to the uk daily mail hunter
biden claimed that russians stole one of
his laptops for blackmail while he was
close to overdosing in a las vegas hotel
room the daily mail can reveal
the alleged incident would mean hunter
lost a total of three computers the
first abandoned delaware computer store
the second seized by federal agents like
this is a weird way to lose computers by
the way like if you've ever lost a
computer it's usually like you were on a
plane and then you just forgot it there
but to lose three
and the first one you abandoned at a
computer store and just forgot about it
and the second one was used by federal
agents and the third was stolen by the
russkies i will say your record with
computers is extremely poor and you
really should think about a more mobile
form of technology at this point
the third laptop apparently is still
missing it was taken by russian drug
dealers after they partied with hunter
in vegas he told a prostitute in a
conversation caught on camera
so here's what happened he filmed
himself having sex with the woman using
his laptop in january 2019 and then
decided you know what we need like some
after role here right it's like the
after the credits section of the sex
tape he left the camera rolling as he
recounted a vegas bender in which he
spends 18 days going around from
penthouse suite to penthouse suite
sometimes costing ten thousand dollars a
night but don't worry guys he is very
well qualified he earned all that kind
of money by being the smartest person
that joe biden knows he didn't use the
biden name in any way shape or form to
get extremely wealthy and then use all
of that money on coke-fueled binges with
multiple prostitutes moving hotel the
hotel
no he's just he's brilliant i mean like
in joe biden's rolodex of brilliant
people that he knows and there's so many
brilliant people he knows i mean his
wife is a doctor for one i mean like the
greatest doctor in all the land and then
you've got hunter who is just a
world-beating businessman like an
incredible incredible businessman
it's it's really an impressive it's an
impressive show so here was a little bit
of what it sounded like when a hunter
was speaking to this prostitute who had
to be like god you're so boring but
you're also paying me two thousand
dollars an hour
ugh i can't like i can't even but at the
same time the money is so good and if i
tell him that this
can of parmesan cheese that i just
picked up at the grocery is coke he will
hand me another hundred thousand dollars
so the prostitute is very uh i would say
lacks
in in allowing him to speak to her this
way here's what the tape sounded like
my computer
had taken tons of like
um like just left like that cam on he
would always put him again like a
passcode another question you know
it was like
i mean
and
somebody's told me the point in that
period
what does the computers have to do
they have videos of me doing this
there is me
crazy effing sex and she's like well
then what did you just pay me for so
that's weird and also
the p tape is real but it stars hunter
biden now the reason we're leading with
this story is number one because it's
hilarious but number two
because if this were donald trump jr you
know that it would lead every network
news
hour for like the next month but it's
hunter biden so he's just a wayward
child guys he's just a small child who's
51 years old
he's just a very small wayward child
who's 14 years my senior that's all
and who happens to be like one of the
worst people i've ever heard of
but also the smartest person that joe
biden knows and who is still going
around like picking up bags of cash
based on his daddy's last name although
now he's become a great artist we know
right
which explains the dissolution usually
you have to be the artist first before
he can be a dissolute artist but he
actually started with the dissolution
and then he became an artist which is
actually going at it's sort of ass
backwards right he started off with the
coke-fueled binges and the and the
benders with prostitutes and then he
moved into making crappy art as opposed
to usually it's the other way around
which is you start off as an artist and
then you like move into the artist
dissolute lifestyle so
he he really likes to do everything i
think in in new and interesting ways as
you know i've been doing a lot of
interviews about the brand new york
times bestselling book the authoritarian
moment and when i have to do an
interview the earbuds that i rely on are
of course my rakons i need them in my
ears because frankly i can't afford to
drop the call they fit my ear perfectly
they've got the gel tips so i can
customize them to fit my ear just the
way i like them to fit they have a
really long battery life like 32 hours
so i'm not always charging them and they
start at half the price of other premium
audio brands and they sound just as good
raycon's come with a 45-day happiness
guarantee as well so you don't have to
take my word for it you can actually try
them out and make sure that you love
them the way that i do again there
there's so much that you can do with
your accounts you can be listening to
podcasts you could be listening to my
brand new audiobook you could be
listening to music you'd be taking phone
calls i do all of the above and you can
as well head on over to buy raycon.com
shapiro yt to get 15 off your raycon
purchase or click the link in the
description box below again go check
them out right now buy raycon.com
shapiro yt get 15 off your raycon order
today brought to you by raycon
so a few things about this one
my understanding is that this means he's
violated like all of the rules of
prostitution okay so hugh grant famously
suggested about prostitution right he
was dating elizabeth hurley you'll
recall he was married to elizabeth early
at the time he had been married to her
um but he was least dating her at the
time and he was stopping prostitutes on
the side and everybody was like wait up
you're married to elizabeth hurley and
you are going to prostitutes and hugh
grant his line about this was i don't
pay them for the sex i pay them to leave
okay well
okay fair enough apparently hunter biden
never really got the message and so he
just talks to the prostitutes also which
is like
okay
all right okay so he's violating all the
rules of prostitution as i understand
them and granted i am not the world's
greatest expert on prostitution but i
feel like these are fairly ironclad
rules one don't use them two
if you are going to use a prostitute
don't talk to them about all your life
problems because you're literally having
to pay them for sex so they don't care
about them and they probably are not
great repositories of information like i
don't think that they are big on the nda
per se like
it doesn't seem like the most
trustworthy crowd i mean i'll be honest
with you okay and then number three if
you are going to talk about all your
life problems being a famous person like
hunter biden if you are in fact going to
do that then probably don't talk on tape
on a laptop right that's rule number
three rule number four if you are going
to one have sex with a prostitute two
talk to the prostitute about all your
life problems three do all of it on tape
on your laptop
then four what you should talk about
should not be
how your prior laptops have been stolen
to your great discontent
because
that creates a sort of incentive
structure for people to steal your
laptop
and it turns out of course that this
laptop did not end up in his hands just
like every other laptop so guys if
you're ever at the airport and you see
hunter biden there and you really have
to go to the bathroom and your laptop is
in your backpack do not ask hunter biden
to watch your backpack do not do it it
is not going to end well in any way
shape or form
what what what a delight hunter biden is
and by the way if you ask questions
about this this means you're bad
how dare you because hunter biden is a
wonderful wonderful man and we know he's
a wonderful man because his last name is
biden and joe biden is a wonderful man
my favorite part of this this is really
great the prostitute asked hunter if he
was worried remember he said that he had
a laptop and the russians stole it quote
from the daily mail the prostitute asked
hunter if he was worried the russian
alleged thieves would try to blackmail
him
hunter replied yeah in some way yeah
my dad is running for president he is i
talk about it all the time if they do he
also knows i i make like a gazillion
dollars
hunter appeared to be dismayed that if
the video was sold by the alleged
thieves to porno news companies he would
be unable to cash in on the explicit
videos himself yeah because there's a
huge market it turns out for hunter
biden sex tapes it's like one night in
paris except with a slightly overweight
dissolute politician's son
the huge market for that sort of thing
he said quote i'm worried he gets the
money up front and maybe it doesn't do a
million dollars maybe it does three
maybe nobody wants to see me naked maybe
it's news interest and because my dad's
a public figure they say we don't have
to pay you anything because you're of
interest in regular news the prostitute
said
i think you should just beat him to the
punch i think you should release your
own video
that's
spectacular okay like i love that hunter
biden the smartest person that joe biden
knows his big business idea is what if i
screw a prostitute put it on my laptop
and then sell the tape
no
i i guarantee you know there's a breed
of man
when he's dating a woman or when he's
trying to date a woman he's not even
dating her when he's trying to date a
woman he thinks that the best available
thing that he can do to woo a woman is
to send a picture of his
right there is that breed of man and
i've always thought who is that guy like
who was the guy who thought you know
what what what this random woman really
wants is a picture of mine we know who
the guy is now the guy's hunter ryden
right he's like i have a money making
proposition for you prostitute lady my
money-making proposition is
we go halfsies on the sacks and then we
also go halfsies on the sex tape or i
pay you nothing
oh but my favorite part there is where
she asks him explicitly
aren't you afraid you'll be blackmailed
and he's like yeah and she's like cool
isn't that what's going on i like
yeah it's it's not it's not good
okay by the way photos on the laptop
hard drive obtained by the daily mail
include pictures of a woman's russian
passport and photos of hunter topless
pulling the woman's brunette hair while
she kneels on a bed other photos show
the woman and three young men driving to
hunter's former hollywood hills rented
home drinking and partying by the pill
by the pool and two women naked with
hunter by the pool it's unclear whether
the russian woman and three men are the
same people hunter accused of stealing
his laptop so the good news is that that
all got sent to the cloud so apparently
he could re-download that to the new
computer to make sure that he had it
with him wherever he went now some
people we like to have pictures of our
wives and our kids on the cloud hunter
has very important things like random
people he has sex with and does drugs
with on the cloud
ah
well
at least he's not the president's son
at least that
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe